this is a production of Cornell
University
after the initial excitement wears off
when people come by to see the titan
arum I'm often asked why do we do this
why do we study strange plants and
unusual plants like this in the grand
scheme of things does it cure disease
does it help us increase crop yield is
it what is it what is it good for in my
mind it's the studying the plants like
the titan arum are simply representative
of discovery based science we don't know
before we do studies what we're going to
learn that's the essence of exploration
and the titan arum and plants like it
are another kind of landscape to explore
in the natural world part of the the
wonders of biological diversity across
the planet so what I like to give
tangible examples to people of what's
interesting and useful about discovery
based science we can start with the
plant itself it's it's biology is
unusual enough to cause us to wonder you
know why would you create why would why
would a plant marshal that much energy
and devote that much of its reproductive
effort to being so large and so stinky
and so hot for such a short amount of
time and then go several years between
reproductive events instead of doing it
every year like migrating birds and when
we take a closer look at what the plant
is doing it's attracting flies and
beetles that are decomposers you know
they their ecological niche is to is to
use rotting materials as as their food
for their for their young for their for
their larvae and grubs etc so one hidden
benefit from studying a plant like the
titan arum is it has been finely tuned
by natural selection to be attractive to
what some humans regard as pest insects
okay so blow flies or screw worms are
the kinds of flies that lay a
or larvae into rotting meat or in some
cases in the case of screw worms into
wounds of animals that are still alive
and so these animals are pests to
agriculture because they cause a lot of
damage to to livestock and so if you
look back in the really applied
scientific literature you'll find Lucy
lore and s worm lure these are code
names or trademarks for for volatile
lures that people use to trap these
flies and keep them away from their
livestock or keep them off of their
farms and so a lot of research went into
that people had to test different
combinations of these noxious odors and
and the right ratios and the right sort
of barcode to attract these flies well
guess what the plants have figured that
out already you know so one immediate
benefit from studying plants like this
which are so so effective at trapping
flies is that there were the
codebreakers they figured it out we
could simply copy them it's a form of
engineering as biomimicry right the idea
of where does velcro come from or the
the feet of geckos that allow them to
walk on slippery surfaces there are
large industries based on using art of
artificial materials to mimic what are
very effective ruses and devices in
nature so here's another one these
plants have picked the code of female
flies and beetles and we can use the
same volatile compounds in the same
ratios that they make as lures has
already been done okay so that's one
example very close to what the plant
does but there's another layer of this
another level of discovery that's really
important and that is the connections
that hidden connections that we don't
see coming I see an example I like to
use with my students is to talk about
modern genomics science okay so this is
a huge huge part of the wedding between
technology and science and medicine and
health is the idea that we now have the
technology to explore genomes not only
the human genome but but the genomes of
other creatures the pathogens that live
in
the creatures that are helpful to us the
animals and plants that we've
domesticated etc but that whole field
the whole edifice of the science of
genomics is built upon serendipitous
discoveries ok so going back to Balby
Ani who was an embryologist in France in
the in the 19th century Val biani
studied something that people would
think was frivolous
you know the salivary chromosomes of
midges kind of little fly mosquito like
fly and ball beyond II was just curious
and what Bal biani discovered was that
they have these polythene chromosomes
that puff up and this was the first way
to visualize genes as beads on a string
before better microscopy and better
genetic technologies were developed in
the early part of the 20th century so
the the foundation of genetics as a
field rests on this kind of frivolous
discovery by Balby Ani about what
salivary gland chromosomes are and
they're in fruit flies as well as midges
and there were our first beads on a
string and genetic dogma but it's more
than that the polymerase chain reaction
PCR this is a way of amplifying rapidly
amplifying specific DNA sequences this
was the invention came out in the late
80s when I was a beginning student and I
remember the you know how fundamentally
it changed the field of genetics but you
can't do PCR without tact polymerase
this is this is a an enzyme DNA
polymerase enzyme that's taken from a
extrema file of bacterium named thermus
aquaticus that lives in hot springs you
know in places like Yellowstone and so
who would study that it's frivolous to
go on a boondoggle with government money
into a national park and scoop out
bacteria from hot springs except it
isn't frivolous because thermos
aquaticus has to do DNA replication in
70 or 80 degrees centigrade water okay
is ridiculous eco lie doesn't do that
common bacteria can't do that
milt so Kary Mullis and the inventors of
principal maurice chain-reaction
realized through a long series of papers
that were that were published over a
decade and a half that tack polymerase
was the tool they needed to solve the
problem of rapid cycling of DNA
amplification and it doesn't stop there
nowadays to visualize you know
transformative genetics you need a
reporter genes and people have used all
kinds of different reporter genes but
the one that's really made a difference
is green fluorescent protein GFP there
was a Nobel Prize given for this
discovery a few years ago but it comes
from a jellyfish and why would you ask
the NIH to support studies of jellyfish
that light up in the water column at
night in the oceans that's frivolous
isn't it but it's not GFP is so
incredibly important and useful and
science is full of those kind of
discoveries these stinky plants that
were studying we don't know ahead of
time whether it's going to give us a
really valuable tool but the way that it
coordinates turning on temperature and
scent and opening and closing and ran
its respiration which is really really
high for a planet it's got molecular
switches it's got nano switches in it we
need to learn from that it could be so
useful to apply what we learn from these
very very specialized plants so that
other plants that are important to us in
our in our in our daily lives
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu